hello there i'm gab i'm dan we're the
slow-mo guys it's been a while dan since
we've used this ridiculous thing i
forgot we had it
but then it's like absolutely ginormous
it's been sat there wanting to be used
this whole time yeah it's been about six
years it's basically an air pressure
tank a solenoid valve and a very long
barrel capable of firing things that are
about this big and spherical
yeah so
basically this it's a three-quarter inch
bb this is a three-quarter inch barrel
so we thought perfect let's try that
last time we used it to fire more
teasers through various objects ping
pong bat was a personal favorite oh
that's the first that's destroyed this
time i thought we could start newton's
cradle
at the highest possible speed we can
manage
what i like about this is essentially
these are pretty hard ball bearings and
we're going to be firing more or less
identical ball bearings straight through
it so it's going to be
very interesting see what happens it'll
be interesting to see even though it's
an order of magnitude
faster in velocity that we're using will
it actually send the final ball
or will it just annihilate the whole
thing it's gonna be a real experiment
but i think a combination of the two
that's what i'm hoping that'll be the
best slo-mo footage yeah absolutely yeah
all right why don't we pressurize this
tank and
see what happens yeah this is the
phantom tmx 7510 very fast camera that
we've used multiple times on this
channel we'll start off at about 82 000
frames a second in 720p i'm using this
perspex water tank as a blast shield i
think it's the right height if i just
move this in
love it
there he is ready to go ready to go
we used this cannon before with
maltesers which were obviously all
different sizes and shapes they were
pretty snug but not
not perfect
but they were good because they were
light
whoa wait what and hard whereas this is
just really hard but also quite heavy
yeah so it needs quite a lot of barrel
to get going
filling the tank okay yep
ready
three two one
flip neck oh the whole thing's gone
yeah there's no balls attached to it
anymore
this one stayed on which one is that the
second one well they're all tangled up
now it's impossible to tell uh the
second one actually no it's the second
one it's actually quite an interesting
sort of physics experience yeah i would
be i'd love to know i'm so excited to
see whether on impact on the first one
does the last one actually go or is it
all just pushed as a big group
well it depends on how hard they are if
they were perfectly hard balls perfectly
hard and there was no defamation
then i'm sure that they would all
act like a perfect newton's crandall the
ball's on its way oh here he comes
booking it
it's smaller so there's no it worked
it's mismatched size isn't it it
sent
it's sent it was okay so not only is the
impacting ball smaller it still had
enough force to batter the front one off
yeah it didn't even like get like
affected and the the further back the
balls are on the newton's cradle the
more they get affected by the the nylon
string holding yeah and they kind of go
up but the way it broke off the front
one
i at least would have thought the
strings would have had some effect on it
like it would have snapped on the way up
oh it snapped as if it wasn't on any
string it had the tiniest effect if you
see it like put a slight bit of spin i
think
flip so i guess the second one is the
one that survived right yeah because it
got hit twice even though it was closer
to the ball that actually impacted it it
forced all of its energy into the next
three balls which went flying and the
first ball took all of the brunt so the
second ball is the is the safest one i
imagine well i'm not disappointed there
should it with a small one with smaller
balls well yeah because that one was
just slightly bigger yeah slightly
smaller you see this little dent here oh
god you see that it's flattened
flattened it and this one has also been
flattened
here see that oh yeah and you see the
original bb is even worse shape
look at that that's what we fired that's
what we fired it's like cracked it's
hard
that's a solid metal though isn't it
yeah i think it is it must be look it
looks like a the death star it does
doesn't it we can make so many tiny bits
it's a scary looking down the damn
barrel no because i know it's not loaded
or anything like that yeah here's the uh
safety measures in place for bloody up
there's literally a huge air gap so even
if there was a ball bearing in there it
wouldn't be
if there was a ball bearing or pressure
or yeah so there's three different
things that is in the way 82 000 frames
a second seems to be plenty for this
you ready ready three two one fire
whoa so this one i went really close up
oh yeah
oh look at that
oh it just snapped that first one
immediately off like
it just didn't even like bother the
nylon it was just like see ya
that's the crazy thing and the last one
snapped off as well the middle two so
the one that receives the impact
immediate snap of the holder
and the last one also like frames apart
that's crazy
and there's still no upward swing on
like any of them no they just go
i think it's definitely right to say
that the
the first ball and the last wall get the
most impact the middle three it goes the
second third and then fourth like the
second is least impacted yeah
and it almost stops dead the first one
in
not in reality but in
incomparable speed and slow-mo if you
look at this this is where the impact
has happened and then on the other side
slightly less energy
but still that's great dennis so i'm
assuming that as you go further down the
balls they'll have a little just get
little dinkier holes starting off with
the death star that's you can tell
smaller you can definitely tell the ones
that were hit with the uh the fired ball
yes i feel like in post i'll definitely
be able to get measurements because we
know the
diameter of that ball yeah and i can
then input that and it'll calculate
speed i just feel like when we had the
malteser cannon
they were going faster they were going
really fast they were going sort of 900
feet per second i believe is what they
said the record was but this is
obviously heavier and there's less
pressure this time it's not using
nitrogen in the vacuum correct we were
doing about 150 before this is about 9
500.
um
we do have another option we've got a
pistol
which fires you know
slightly faster than the speed of sound
yeah so that should have more beans if
you're worried about the lack of beans
so you're saying you can from a safe
distance place
a pistol shot
into the side of a newton's cradle
i can try
i reckon i need to be at least sort of
15 20 foot yeah away you want to
describe the ammunition we're using
today yeah it's a 9 by 19 which means 9
mm caliber 19 length of the cartridge
it's ball round or fmj so it means it's
got like a
softer sort of cupro
nickel type coppery metal on the outside
of the of the central lead and that's to
engage in the rifling it's sort of a
standard pistol ammunition um
used for like target practice things
like that
uh
it's just above speed of sound about
1200 feet per second let's uh take
hundreds of thousands of pictures of
them as they sail through the air
it's going to be a hell of a shot
if it works
but an absolute hell of a shot
made ready
are you ready yep
i missed but
it's okay
safe
huh try again
ready
whoa
i don't know what i hit i don't think it
was the balls oh it's below the balls
oh
look at this
that's the way you put it yeah perfectly
central to where the balls are
except too low
so it went in and then flipped the whole
thing up hit the table and then bounced
up into the bottom yeah pretty much
here it is still warm
ready
oh i hit a ball i think
maybe not
i can't really tell
see what it did
maybe i was just completely off
[Laughter]
god
no surely
never
never
it did less
it put less momentum into the front one
than the ball bearing oh my god that
bullet got wrecked
get rekt son the thing is right i saw
the ball bearing go flying down range
yeah
and i was like i think i've hit one and
then i went and i was like well i can't
have done because there's still four
balls on four balls on there that was a
great shot it was a hell of a shot
a hell of a shot is it just that less
dense yeah it's not as weird there's not
as much mass behind it and it's also not
as hard as the ball bearing the ball
bearings are much harder that's why if
you have like just went to pieces it's
because the ball bearings are harder and
and it doesn't have as much weight but
mostly the hardness that's unbelievable
that's unexpected when i saw all the
balls on there yeah i thought uh it's
probably a messy but you might glance
the plank and i watched it play back and
i was just usually i try and keep my
reaction so that we can watch it
together i was just watching it off
camera i just went no
that was so good as soon as i saw
this
on the base i knew i'd hit the ball
because the because it's exploded
because it's exploded it's just gone
from and all this is what the bullet did
after it just went to pieces
the mangled remnants of
of newton's credit i think i think isaac
would be happy with what we've done
today he would approve he's looking down
on us thinking yes boys yeah he's
definitely a
smile on his face as he looks up on us i
just can't believe that the pistol
didn't do much
unbelievable i'm so shocked it's like
the pistol hit a solid steel wall yeah
in terms of how it
just shattered to pieces and the wall
just went yeah yeah but this is the
newton's cradle that's in the best shape
after being hit by the ball
and this is the pistol one
surprisingly good shape yeah and uh it
must just be the heft of the ball and
the hardness of the ball that makes the
difference rather than the
bullet yeah still works perfectly just
return it i'd give that to her just
return it
wow
lovely sunset as well i'm i enjoyed that
it was a good day hopefully you enjoyed
that video as much as we enjoyed making
it subscribe if you love slow-mo uh
click on the bell yeah yeah make sure
you get notifications there is that bell
that's about it good shout see you next
time see you next time